étranger
j'ai aimé pouvoir m'exprimer et à la
fois visuellement artistiquement
routinier
je suis fier d'être moi-même
Veronica et cela devrait être universel
euh pour toutes les cultures donc c'est dommage
que certaines personnes essaient de revendiquer
leur unicité oui au point ou
les républicains
c'est  juste un gaspillage inutile de l'argent des contribuables
[Musique]
une femme
met inutilement des interprètes
comme moi en danger pour des crimes potentiels à la maison
et des drames et des blessures et de possibles
crimes de haine
en général, j'ai beaucoup soutenu
et je pense que je peux parler au nom de
beaucoup de conservateurs  aussi Noah Jenkins
University Vanderbilt pour un public adulte,
bien sûr, c'est divertissant et vous savez que les
adultes ont la capacité de porter
un jugement par eux-mêmes.
moi, cela me rendra plus
conscient parce que quiconque regarde
l'émission a le potentiel d'appeler à
une arrestation ou à une enquête, nous avons
d'énormes baies vitrées ici, les fenêtres
s'ouvrent les beaux jours, nous voulons qu'elles soient
complètement ouvertes,
alors nous '  re beaucoup de gens ont dit oh
vous devez les bloquer à
l'étranger
spécifiquement interdit les actes sexuels
aux yeux des mineurs
quand je vois des images de certains euh des
spectacles de drag qu'ils jouent vraiment
une nature extrêmement provocante quand je
vois  euh le cheerleading arrive par exemple
c'est euh aérobie en faisant quoi en ajoutant du
maquillage et un type de vêtement spécifique
c'est ce qui nous rend plus dangereux c'est
l'orientation sexuelle ou l'
identité de genre de cette personne dont ils ont
peur
Tennessee
[Musique]
il y a un profond  chagrin mais aussi colère,
je veux dire que nous sommes en colère contre la législation, la
façon dont elle est écrite, cela affecte également
nos personnes trans non binaires et
non conformes au genre, car
le langage est si vague que
nous n'avons pas de directives claires pour la
législation
mais nous explorons toutes les options que nous
consultons
avec des experts juridiques pour déterminer la
meilleure ligne de
conduite
la nouvelle législation ne dit pas que je
ne peux pas lire de livres devant des enfants, elle
dit simplement que je ne peux rien faire de sexuel
pendant que je lis des livres aux enfants, le
chef titulaire de l'université Al au stade intermédiaire du
Tennessee,
la communauté LGBT euh est définitivement euh des
cibles en ce moment euh ça euh tu sais combien
de temps ça va durer comment riposter euh
ce sont tous des problèmes que cette communauté
est  va devoir faire face à je vais
vous montrer, euh,
ils ont assez bien fait ce qu'ils veulent
faire à la fois sur les armes à feu et le choix, alors maintenant vous
devez chercher d'autres moyens de
nourrir la bête, je me sens certainement mal que
les gens se sentent  ciblé en ce sens que j'essaie de
les encourager et d'essayer de les faire se sentir
mieux en disant que ce projet de loi n'est pas
destiné à Cibler un groupe social particulier
dans la société que nous essayons de faire est
de protéger les enfants de la société contre le
contenu qu'ils ne sont pas  prêt à voir que
nous avons eu quelqu'un qui a commenté là-bas qui a
dit oh non, nous ne
permettons plus cela, nous espérons que
vous avez une bonne sécurité car nous
vous fermerons
je suis ici tant qu'ils m'auront je  Je
veux dire à moins qu'ils ne me donnent un ticket de bus
et me virent, je ne vais pas
exister
[Musique]